welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz today I'm
joined by conahey who is the team lead
or a team leader walk 3d you are a
specialist recruiting agency that
operating data and analytics Connor
Connor manages a small team of three
including himself and has been in
recruitment for just over 18 months so
Connor excited to talk and uncover your
story so far I think I must just say
that we'll see how we got to this point
in corner sort of proactively reached
out I said I've been listening to the
podcast and would love to just talk a
bit about some of the things that I've
done learning it cetera the last a year
and a half and no I think it's so
important to not for me there's no
benchmark to get involved this podcast
right so luck for me she's so important
to give and people like you wear on your
career to sort of say how it's going
what you've learned blah blah blah
there'll be a lot of people that listen
to this there and are where you are or
even before right and definitely if
you're someone that has the right
mindset you should have the mindset that
you can learn from anyone I mean I think
it's so important so and super excited
to sort of unpack the last 18 months
obviously I know that when we initially
Spidey was on furlough and you've been
back for a couple of weeks so be good to
would definitely cover sort of that
experience but I think a lot of people
can relate to that the way I always like
to start on this podcast Connor is how
the Quanah hey enter the world of
recruitment let's start there yeah a
good starting place and thanks for
having me on
hisham it's really good to be a part of
this this podcast has helped me in many
ways during my 18 months so I'm sure we
can come onto that as well
yeah in terms of my journey into
recruitment I probably rather unique
that any of you've ever had anyone on
your podcast who used to be or trained
to be a Catholic priest before no I
suspected that might be the answer
but yeah that was my former path post
University I was traded to the Catholic
priest in Rome yeah yeah I mean it was
great in many ways you know the pizza
the wine bet some good friends yeah I've
been trying to shake off the weight like
still trying to do it now
Rome is like if you don't have which we
straight on food and drink it's not the
place to live but it was super fun while
it lasted and yeah just like decided
that wasn't the right thing for me and I
think really actually what helped me
make my choice was when I went to see
the rector I was going to say if anyone
knows who the rector is but Rex is a
word you don't get doesn't get thrown
around that's right so just to just to
kind of clear you in on that the right
to is kind of like the headmaster off
like the priests Training College so to
speak I don't think he thanked me for
giving him that summary but that's like
effectively what they're for discipline
on anyway I went to see here instead I
look you know I want to leave and he
said to me it's only right when you're
making a big choice in life to seek the
wisdom of a lot of people and he mainly
said that because we were supposed to be
going on this retreat next week and he
wanted me to stay and to see if I was
gonna gonna decide to stay rogue so I
thought that was good advice and I took
that into my job and so I know that
loads of people fall into recruitment
but that wasn't me really I think I took
some time to consider like hey what am I
going to be happy doing and be like what
matches up with my with my skill set I
thought I took that advice from the
rector of like speak to loads of
different people get a feel of jobs yeah
it's the most natural thing for me to
have done would have been to teach it's
a bit of a joke most people who drop out
the priesthood they go into teaching
because most of the time in seminary
it's not spend like you know learning
teaching was the most natural path I
think that was a good lesson in itself
actually not just to follow like what's
expected I think that was a good thing
to me to take some time into to work
stuff out so yeah I spoke to like loads
of different people got a feel of jobs
recruitment what took because what my
friends did it for like
he did fall into it just for some money
I said fair enough his wallet shot but
yeah he gave me a bit of the picture so
I did that to kind of my catalogue of
jobs right
just thought I'd really explore
everything really and yeah I think why
are they need on recruitment to actually
pursue it was really looking at yeah
what skillset enjoy
so it skill set wise I guess it was
really the ability to kind of
communicate with other people understand
people's problems and situations like a
lot of training we got in Rome as I
understanding people's positions and
trying to provide a solution as well I'm
in many ways obviously in a very
different way but we still have the same
kind of skills so that appealed to me
and I also just liked the idea that
recruitment was like meritocratic you
spent Irish dancer as well played
cricket see I've done small things in my
life I was all that stuff appealed to me
and then yeah God went through a great
rhetoric
she got me three interviews from
recruitment companies and that was
really like when I started to discover
what it was like I guess really about
how civilized in those interviews or
those interview processes so yeah I had
those three interviews that they all
progressed kind of similar speed and
yeah I landed on all three D and I'm
really glad I did sweet nice okay
interesting story thank you for sharing
definitely unique I love that I think I
think you're completely right I think
what I love that you said about that is
basically you empathy right being
empathetic being able to understand
people with different situations listen
so I totally understand why that's a
skill set that you probably had to grow
and become better with if you were
trying to be a priest some preacher
would be a good listener and yeah you I
have people sort of see where they can
solve their problems or whatever right
so I really like that that's cool so and
okay then so very quickly what's so all
3d what what so I guess just in out of
interest why did you what sort of drew
you to them
stay out of the other two businesses and
what's what we helped you make that
decision you know that's yeah that
that's a great question so there were a
couple of things I think firstly like it
was quite nice actually just in general
that I was going through those processes
at the same time and I was kind of
getting to a similar stage or I could
assess them kind of on like an even keel
I guess so all three news you mentioned
we do a lot in data analytics we also
have a team leaders cybersecurity as
well but like you know fast growth
technology really there was another
company who did something similar and
then the third company did like they
were more established and they did a lot
in the insurance sector I think for all
3d for me there was a couple of like key
things a big one for me was the size of
the company and it would put put
people's from people off they were only
make five people I was the six the first
external hire for them a lot of them
came from the previous recruitment
company they don't work together but I
quite liked that like for me like the
start-up feel and being able to be a
part of something and to grow something
of course it's always like riskier for
sure but I think that really appealed to
me a second thing that like stood out
was the training like my bosses were
huge on like the training I was going to
get also because it was so small I could
like really tap into their knowledge and
I knew that was going to be key cuz I
was so conscious that like I need
absolutely nothing about recruitment
yeah I did experience so I was so
conscious of like yeah the potential for
me to be really bad at it and I really
wanted to be able to have people I could
learn from learn from yeah and not only
just what my directors actually like
because we were so smaller than our
investor who's been a great mentor to me
I managed to get quite a lot of time
with him and he successfully grew a
recruitment company and he invests in
recruitment businesses now and he stayed
a good mentor for neither and I not join
them at that time would have been more
difficult to establish the relationship
so I think those were two key things
want final thing to quickly mention I
think is the vision I think that's super
important like I really bought into the
vision of the directors they articulated
it so passionately it was something I
bought into and I think that was key for
me like if I was going to give it my all
because let's face it recruitments not
not easy kind of you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of down days as well as
new days and I think yeah you really
need something that you believe in to
drive you in those times so I think the
vision that we had at all three D of the
growth plans which is still still
stand-in and still go in and I've gone
well you know so far pretty kind of
lockdown and things but yeah that that
kind of really helped me as well buying
into what they believed in the agenda
that yeah that's really interesting okay
so how were your first couple of months
of equipment first couple of months are
actually like performance wise like not
great to make your first placement it
was so it was for four months in freely
yeah no in fact sorry no I was supposed
to have something go into April she I
was in Morocco on holiday I think yeah
but she pulled out so actually my first
place believes in a yeah I was I mean of
course it was the right thing for her
right so it was yeah so five months yeah
five months of like my interviews were
what goodbye CV sounds like we were lots
of stuff happening but in short I had
final interviews so I've kind of like
quite kind of heard that introduction to
be honest it might really taught me a
lot in terms of mental resilience and
mindset and also I think it turned out
that first year turned out to be a bit
of a metaphor for recruitment because I
have no placements and then in May I
build fifty five and a half K kids have
a gay so I mean yeah that was like you
know that outweighed big time you know
and then yeah the rest of the year went
really really well and I could have ever
imagined so yeah the first few months
were like really really tricky like just
because of lack of results and the
mental challenge that brings especially
when you starting something new and you
just want to impress big time I mean
you just feel let's just let's just talk
about that because I think that's
relatable to someone there's more years
down the line and they have a bit of a
tough spell which happens like how did
you get through those mum like it's the
mental part right it is it's you
balancing yourself like [ __ ] I'm like
should I even be in this job and is this
ever going to change
get the self-doubt that ends up sort of
coming through and your phone calls
you're not as confident so like how did
you what was the things that really
helps you get through that tough patch
yeah I think if you've hit something
there yeah you know whether you're new
or whether you're seasoned you know
you're always going to have those those
difficult matches I think you're right
the self-doubt creeps in big-time so for
me it was it was a few things really I
think to summarize one of them was was
really doing a lot of work on my mind
sadly I think like just like you work
out your body like working out your mind
and your mindset is something that's
really important and that's actually
helped me and continues to help me a lot
now so I took took advice of a lot of
people in terms of reading books to read
things that help me all that kind of
stuff
books what books for the impact there's
been some really good ones over the last
18 months I think during that time the
first book I read actually it was quite
probably a stark introduction to reading
it was the ten actual my grant cardone
and given like I've never read a like
pretty intense out that it's a pretty
big shift from the Bible I certainly
like any okay so 10x Gronk on bone yeah
thanks what did that help you was any
other books that really helped 10x
helped there was a book called called by
my boss helped me and introduced me to
that
and yes I think that that was a big
thing for me you touched on the
self-doubt before for me it wasn't as
much like self doubt that was there but
a big factor for me and I think it's a
lot of people really hard I see it a lot
and I think it's people who want high
standards they're usually people who
achieve well but there are also people
or can be people who are very hard on
themselves I was so hard on myself in my
first year like really hard
investor when we were chatting and he
sat down home to me and he was like look
he said you got to snap out of this are
you never going to enjoy it if you you
know I'd achieve more than I thought I
could yeah all that was focusing on was
like the one big place so when you start
focusing on the negatives that was like
a real big thing to overcome as well
because yeah in recruitment they're
always going to be there if you choose
to focus your time and attention on them
you're gonna be screwed mentally so yeah
the power of now was actually a really
really good book and then so then
anything else that you did or continue
to do now that sort of it's become sort
of non-negotiable for you maybe habits
or sort of your own personal rituals
that have just helped you mentally with
the sort of pitfalls the ups and downs
yeah so I think I mean my habits have
changed they've changed a lot for the
better over the last 18 months I'm
actually currently doing the miracle
morning
you know myself or my boss for doing a
30 day challenge so I'm actually taking
along all that so that's kind of my new
routine but I think in general just like
over the last 18 months things that are
non-negotiable about it certainly the
reading so I can read every day I mean
it's like background before what so
quite like reading and learning seeking
feedback as well that's like a habit
that I really really tried to look at
particular at my first year but even now
it's like you can always be learning so
much off of the people and I think that
comes from like it feels it feels ironic
sometimes to say oh I'm a humble person
because by nature it seems been made but
what I mean by that is I recognized that
there's no way I can do this by myself
we recognize the need for help so
that's the big thing for me but yeah in
terms of hobbies will we speed my
positivity in the morning that's key my
mornings have become super key always
feed my mommy positivity exercises when
also when gyms are open I'm using the
gym in the morning at the moment and
lots of walking down but that just gives
me like clarity of mind and kind of just
gives me time to really have some time
for myself as well before the day kicks
in yeah finally probably just getting my
diary in order like in the morning
that's because after then a call comes
in and before you know positivity
exercising getting like a good structure
and for the rest of the day like they've
been pretty person loved that so and
lasting that then under and then we'll
talk about sort of the shift and what
went on after those five months but sort
of looking back none we know now what
would you say to Connor before you enter
those five months you think what would
you say good question I mean I think in
one way I wouldn't change anything that
happened yeah so much from the mistakes
like I learned a lot more from the
mistakes I did from the winds but I
think if I was to give myself some
advice that would have made me
significantly better I think it would
have been first is I just touched on
would be go easier on yourself because I
mean I was draining myself like every
day like fretting about you know nothing
happening or nothing or nothing I
perceived as positive happening cuz I
was so focused on the short-term and the
results and that's a big thing for me
now is I always look at the big picture
and the long-term and I know things will
work themselves out if you trust in a
repeatable process that you know works
things will work out in the long run and
that's what happened over the course of
the year but in those five months I was
mentally draining myself and so yeah
that's another thing I'd say trusting
trust in the process don't panic and go
of course because I always knew
especially it was like alright see than
me or the process and you know sometimes
you start doing your own thing and
trying to make other stuff happen and I
think he's just like back to basics and
particularly like when you're kind of
early on and I think third and
finally something I'd say to myself is
I'm still working on this now again I've
got a good book on this actually but
it's like learning to be uncomfortable I
think that was the big thing like trying
to just be confident and know that
growth comes from being uncomfortable I
think that's the key thing because I
hold you back from so much that can make
you so successful and to help you
achieve your goals so yeah those are the
three amazing so just just for context
five months so it's what you're sick no
your fifth month was May where you build
50 over 50k
so your your is this perm yeah yeah okay
so then just for context and then we'll
talk about uncover sort of the first
year what changed etcetera but like what
did you then end up finish in year one
on in tonnes of billions wise yes
finally finished 174 in year one my
target was my initial target was 67 and
a half but then I hit that in month six
and I went to 75 so I finished yeah I
finished to 32% target and finished to
talk revenue generator in the company as
well which I was yeah I super happy with
that my first year yeah honestly that
that's amazing one and nothing is I
think that's just the prime as you said
the perfect metaphor recruitment right
okay so let's just took like what what
change do you think like if you think I
don't know was there a moment where I
was like I just get it you do have those
sort of moments where things click or as
you said he was trusting in the process
but what do you think changed it's a
good question I don't think there was
like the light switch moment where I was
like right I've you know I've got this
nailed you know I still have I mean I've
had a good year this year as well but
like self-doubt still creeps in
sometimes right when you're having those
little patches but I think I really
learnt yet to trust in the process we've
got over them but that was a real big
thing for me was like once it was almost
like the floodgates open and Mae was
like
right you know this hasn't just cooked
from something I've done in the last
week or last two weeks it's coming from
the fact that you know I've been doing
the right things consistently for enough
period of time that you have to be I
think in the long term if you do the
right things over a long period of time
you have to be unlucky to to kind of not
at least do okay so that was one thing I
think the second thing though was like I
just really really read like a lot of
books
yeah and just absorbed a lot of content
like even if you don't like reading
because sometimes people say oh I'm
reading so that's fair enough but
there's like audio books there's YouTube
there's like videos on LinkedIn there's
webinars those like whatever you want to
tap into it's there to tap into and I
think I just really really like became
almost obsessed with consuming content
about sales
not just recruitment we're just about
sales and just about mincer and I think
that helped me a lot as well and there
was some much specific sales I guess
sales people I looked at I looked a lot
a grant cardone and he he did help me
actually kind of it's wacky right and
you know some people hate him but love
him or hate him he has a lot to offer I
believe and he really taught me the idea
of just 10x in activity and just allowed
me to think what's actually possible
because his output is crazy and I
thought I was doing okay so really
helped me just raise my levels and raise
my bar actually and there was a couple
of other like sales you know videos and
people I watched as well so I think that
was a big thing was learning and
development trusting in the process and
just becoming yeah becoming more putting
myself in situations that I used to back
out of I think like whatever being
honest like it sounds stupid say like
there's a recruiter now nice it wasn't I
was scared of the phone but for example
I put it in the extra hard yards I'm
actually doing the hand-to-hand cause I
actually bring in a decision makers I'm
following up on emails and comm call in
and you know doing all that stuff it's
like you can get away with not doing it
sometimes and people do they were just
like send out the message and you might
find one or two people but I just
learned or tried to just really the more
uncomfortable I got I found them
results I was getting really yeah yeah
like and again yeah no I think that's
true I think the more you could make
yourself uncomfortable in the kind of
sales environment yeah the more he helps
me just kind of repeat that in the
future it's always hard it's the first
time you do something but I think yeah
the more conversations I put myself into
the more I asked for referrals the more
I called cold you know because one of my
biggest clients like he's a company
based in the US it was one of my first
it was my first cost be like he'd
applied to LinkedIn that message that's
how he's like what about me business
though we've changed a lot our processes
since then it's been part of the journey
being a start-up and about Boston I just
give them a call and I was like yeah
yeah sure a title that was like CEO he
was president before of this community
companies probably almost he was like
hey man is that you in a cave I was like
the signal was so bad it's like call me
back so I'm like crap in it because I
have to go bring the guy again and go
through the anyway he's he's still that
company's still my biggest client so I
think having that experience of like
right actually if I do the hard things
but I know I don't have to do but if I
do them I'll do better that mindset
pushed me on for the rest of the year
then and I think having that tangible
example early on of like right that
actually led to like you know half my
yearly target was I if that can happen
it won't happen but if I could if I know
my head that can happen every time I'm
just gonna quad you're not give yourself
that just won't do whatever it takes
yeah yeah exactly so how did because I
think a lot of people can read and a lot
of people like there's so much
information out there now but I think
you have to apply it right so how have
you got a better sort of light or how we
made sure that you're not someone that
just sits there and consumes content and
does [ __ ] all with it like like do you
not I mean because I think there's so
many so on the books the people like
there's
the things that I love consuming Tony
Robbins was one of the first people that
I went to I went to unleash the power of
in two years ago and and like so and I
think you can very easily just always be
consuming always be looking for that
sort of perfect way of doing other no
just always looking for something that
you think and solve your problem but
actually it's got a big combine of a lot
of action and also as you know if anyone
listens or follows bank lending it's all
about actually right so here like I
don't know what would how have you made
like what's your thoughts on how have
you made sure that you haven't been
someone that's just taken it in and not
done anything cause I think a lot of
people are those people ya know I think
that's I think that's really fair and
it's very easy to do you can get swept
up in the moment and then it's forgot
about him
yeah kudos I love Tony Robbins as well
so he's been someone else I've kind of
read and consumed but yeah I think I
think you're right there it's like
action action is key and that's what
creates habits right and that's really
what I think I've managed to do is
cultivate some good habits I've still
got things I need to work on but I think
that's been part of it is like for
example if I consume something
hey I don't expect that everything I
could assume is going to like you know
kind of really resonate with me I think
you get a couple of ideas from a book or
from a video and you'll get the odd
thing that really hits you so I don't
try and apply everything I read I think
that's the first thing it can be like
way too much I think really like
resonate with you and but you actually
think right actually that could make a
difference that could help me and then
what I would do is I'd make a conscious
effort because usually you know I've
listened to a book on the way into work
after work and still take you a good
week or two to get through it so if I
picked up on an idea I really liked I'd
set part and part of my goal setting in
the morning would be I'm gonna action
that specific thing and really try and
pin it down so it might be for example
trying to think of something that's a
good example I guess some I've actually
had one recently this wasn't something I
read like it was kind of an idea about
by myself so part of the miracle morning
is these like affirmations and
zatia and that was like super foreign to
me I was like this is really weird day
one in my bedroom at 5 +5 I try to like
visualize my life it did it did help in
some ways and what I took from that was
like having an affirmation and having a
visualization like keeping in mind why
you do what you're doing I think that
really helped me for example sounds like
right okay I need to actually make sure
I do that so if on my cold-call blocks
now as I start and this will sound crazy
to some people but in the short term as
I start like be grateful I will make
some affirmations you know be grateful
for what you've got and be grateful for
the opportunity and I let that fuel me
and just before someone picks up the
phone you always say that like anything
okay now I'm here I always say to myself
I'm probably not gonna die in my head
and then I go for it but that's for
example my dear ones from the
visualization but what I did was I made
it my goal and I wrote it in my diary
every days I'm gonna do that become a
habit I know I find myself just saying
all the time try to ring my friend I
think that's like a really key thing for
action is find a couple of ideas that
resonate yeah overwhelm yourself and
dedicate you know the week or two to
really enough to move on because it only
takes a few weeks and I love that really
good advice what what's been the most
impactful thing you've learned you think
that's sort of helped you in cell biz
development or just just in that sort of
common up to the end of that
yeah you said obviously reading and
learning you really just immerse
yourself in that but anything that
sticks out the Sun has really impacted
you and has really helped mmm you know I
think in terms in terms of business
development obviously like given the
current situation that's like you know
that's most most of my role since
returning from furlough in the last few
weeks has been really heavy heavy on
business development which I enjoy but I
nevertheless
is you know it's tough tough grind every
day so I think yeah that not that life
of a shoe thing I mentioned is it's kind
of helping me but I think like a big
thing for me and it's come across in a
few different books actually I think
simon Sinek start with why it's one
there's a book via smart man send
something off not giving a [ __ ]
something like that
well good the different books and Ikes I
mean I've really picked up that she's
like like keep the wire at the front of
your mind like why are you doing this
because I found like you know the crap
days in the criminal weeks on months and
let's face it they all they all happen
and I bear the a-team and said I'm sure
people which were seen you've had much
more troubling periods for longer
periods of time but I think like when he
gets like that it's like there are
various things that help you through but
one big thing that helps me push myself
is help me maybe make the extra calls or
send the extra emails or work on the
personalized video reach or whatever
he's like and that's something I've
learned is to be able to dream a lot
bigger it was very good I was helped not
helped us but he like severs on the path
of trying to put together a life plan
and when you like 25 that's like really
really difficult but especially in this
like environment there's so many
variables right so but actually working
towards that and having a clear picture
of course that might change you know
it's like here's what I want and if I
want to get there I know I need to do by
this action and all this cord lock or
this whatever it is that's gonna help me
get there and I think that's really a
big thing for me now it's like I'm just
everything I do I try and do it with a
purpose I love that that's so that's
yeah I think if you haven't even thought
about that that's when you can find it
really tough because if you're yeah
that's that's gonna really compel you to
carry on and make those difficult calls
and yeah I think that honestly I think
that's amazing that you've really been
able to cultivate that mindset and think
about it that way so early on and and
not think about it as just a job and
I've got hit my sales numbers or
whatever right
okay so let's talk about um sort of
going into the second year and we'll
segue into sort of I'd love to
definitely talk about the business
development piece and in the current
market because I think a lot of people
be experienced in that but how did you
because I know that we'll see had a
really good start to this year right has
a really good first quarter and and then
obviously coronavirus right so I'm sure
you as finking 2020 it's my year got my
goals down all that right and but you
got off to a good start what do you what
did you build in your first quarter yes
and I build 115 you want not bad is it
no it's okay you know he can't complain
just quickly and and just for context
because now you mentioned it but is that
all abroad sorry or is it yeah yeah so
like when I first started I was doing
some stuff in the UK so my first year
yes about my placement for the UK in the
u.s. I always did the US and UK and at
the end of last year I kind of really
focused all my energy and time on the US
so yeah I did the US market and what was
they so at the moment there's three of
us who do the u.s. in my team and we all
cover the whole of the US so critical
mass really we do a lot in New York you
know that's probably a big hope yeah
throughout the US is a big super big
culture over there if I'm in remotely
and so many of my customers will just
say I don't care why they're based so
it's super helpful to have that coverage
so yeah big old territory at the minute
and hopefully as we grow our team you
know that's that's gonna yeah okay so
before we talk about sort of then yeah
how we like the period of going big on
furlough and how you sort of found that
blah blah blah and how was it was what's
it been like penetrating the US market
like what are some of the things that
you've had to learn or
you've had to change your approach will
see your point in the UK right so like
for like what what there's sort of
nuances that you've had to adapt to and
picked up on but how has it actually
been sort of selling and building
relationships and being a recruits in
the UK but for the US market yeah good
question I'd only put it down on the UK
there I love British people but actually
the u.s. like just super positive on the
whole of course you're always going to
get like you know a bad reception from
from some people and you know that's
just the nature of sales right but on
the whole like yeah people in the US are
actually really receptive to kind of
hear my opportunities and you know BD is
a bit easier so actually yeah it's it's
kind of wise be a bit easier
people will well twofold actually
firstly it's easier to get like contact
details within the US they don't buy
into the whole GDP things CV really good
people don't get pissed off really when
you ring them on the whole it's really
ya know really like of course like every
week I get a handful of people who
aren't you have interrupted that day
which is fair enough
so I get it but yeah on the whole
they're a bit more receptors at least
here in you I find so it's not
necessarily to convert is they normally
will give you that opportunity to do
like your personal pitch and why you're
called yeah yeah they'll normally let
you say who you are why you call in and
then if you're not interested they'll
let you know but they'll at least not me
hear you out so I think they have a
slightly different perception or
approach may be different in the UK it's
not been quite as positive on the cold
cold outreach calls right so yeah I
found that that's such the bit of an
interesting difference they're a bit
more receptive to hearing from that's
interest in and and have you not had
pushed back then on like you're in the
UK or I don't know like how do you
approach that yeah I know so we have
like on the whole no I'd say most people
don't don't flag it but yes certainly
some companies like why should I work
with you when there's you know hundreds
of recruiters in new
I think for this how do you handle that
how do you handle that objection
yes it always falls back to me I'm like
well it's the strength of my network
right so I've been doing you know the us
since day one so 18 months but
predominantly like full force for like
12 really of like all of us pretty much
so for me is that well that's what my
network is you know that's where I
already have people who could be
relevant to you and that's usually like
a good kind of pitch in sign also got
some like let's got a good video case
study of a client I work with in Boston
who did to my great work for us just to
like how good it's been to where others
and also like how the time zone and all
that stuff isn't really much of a kind
of difference for them so but yeah I
think that's the big thing is like it's
just what your network is is that you
with like how connected we are in this
day and age you can kind of do any
market right and then and then have you
found a lot of people service the fees
are bigger in America like have you
found it easier to knit up so you did a
bit the UK obviously we all know UK
people in your office on this they will
do us but like have you found that
you've been able to negotiate and higher
percentages your question yeah so we
don't we don't be too much of the UK we
do have some you have some clients in
the UK other guy just Europe as well but
yeah on the whole I'd say negotiation in
the u.s. is yeah it's usually pretty
reasonable
you usually get pretty close to specific
well on average what would you say that
average percentage is typically because
in the UK is I mean if you're in a good
place it's like 20 maybe more than that
right if you if you're decent and but a
lot of people be working at 15% during
this period able to draw that
potentially the 10% and under like so
what what have you found has typically
been this or that Ridge percentage you'd
been answer yeah good question I think
on average it probably is 20 or maybe
slightly higher I'd say 20 and we get a
few at 22 and a half 24 live so probably
2013 the salary yeah so the salaries are
pretty good to be fair especially when
you do in states like New York
you know like San Francisco as well just
like the standard of living is so much
higher and I remember like one of my
first first cause of all 3d like Barry
mind the background I come from I was on
like 250 pound a month for my training
it was not a lucrative like I remember
in May in my like big big month of
commission I really I remember working
out it was something insane yeah so but
yeah I can't say that oh yes so one of
my first phone calls you know obviously
a skin-like
so what your expectations for you next
role and the guy said something like
okay and I was trying to be professional
no other phone oh yeah yeah sure sure
but yeah the salaries over there pretty
good so what's been your average fee
yeah some average fears of company is
around 15k pounds
yeah like I've had I mean in the US I
mean that's like it could be out for
Drive and we do different different
geographies but in the u.s. like I had
two two this year one was 40k dollars
one was 30k dollars so you can get some
pretty decent views over that okay so
let's just talk a bit about being on
furlough great start to the year
kroehner virus hits we'll see America
has been hit bad as well right how how
like what what was going through your
head like I don't know how did you do it
so how long was your furlough for six
weeks how how was it um yeah it's funny
like I think you've put it in a good way
there that was my mindset like I've had
a really good q1 I had had some stuff
that was going into q2 some solid like
last-minute deals that were pulled as
everyone probably has experienced but
yeah from like the psych
psychological standpoint I was like yeah
this can be a tremendous year I don't
want to sort of like the rook support
underneath your fee and you know things
dropped out super quick and all that but
yeah to me furlough was like
it was okay you know I just tried to
make the most of it because I knew that
it was the best thing for the company I
think like I really feel for people who
were on furlough you know some people
say oh well it's you know you're often
you getting paid so I think like for me
or from my perspective like when you're
that part of a company and the type of
people that like good recruiters on are
on the type of people we try to hire
right they really really want to help
that company in a tangible way and they
want to make a difference and the
hardest thing to do when you have that
mindset I think is to set on the bench
so to speak and not be able to make a
tangible difference so I think like that
bit is hard but yeah I just kind of
tried to make the most of it and just
think well it's the best thing for the
company so I will you know I'm I'm
sacrificing myself in a different way
I'm not doing the hard Biddy yards but I
am saving them cash flow and helping
them and so that's kind of how I viewed
it really I just took those a time to
read try and do some things I enjoyed
and relax I've come back nice and fresh
but yeah my - you
the two people in my team that coming
back on 1st July so not long they've
been off even longer than me I stayed on
for a little while so they've been off
quite a while and yeah they're just
chomping at the bit to get back and I
think that's the big thing I've noticed
since returning it's like part of like
life for me and like not to get too deep
but it's really about doing something
purposeful like finding something
meaningful and adopting responsibility
and like really going for that goal and
I think like when you can't work that's
like really hard to do because a lot of
people's goals and purpose and what they
want to achieve is around their career
right sure yeah it was difficult in some
ways but also yeah I try to take it it's
like right this is the only chance I'll
get before I retire to do this try and
try and be positive and just try and do
what I can do and yeah it just did some
golf dissing reading and all that stuff
it was ok but I'm glad to be back and
what what was it like getting back
because I think this is what's gonna be
interesting right I'm record as a
podcast earlier with I think I think
there's a bit of a balance that like six
weeks on furlough
like my my girlfriend's been on followed
from the very beginning and it's been a
roller coaster right good days bad days
more productive weeks less productive
weeks but I think if you're someone
there's found it really hard to be
productive and you get the analogy that
a lot of people even use in which
nothing is a good one is off the bench
and on the pitch right yeah like that
it's gonna be you're gonna it's gonna
hit you like a ton of bricks as to what
the markets actually like right so as
you said you've been solidly business
development units get business on roles
that you can work some assuming that you
have a significant drop in positions so
coming back or furlough but as you said
golf reading relaxed into the quote
unquote real world what was that what
was it actually like what what what was
you most surprised about yeah I think I
slightly underestimated how difficult
those first few days would be it would
be an honest it's a super Swift
hard-hitting transition from doing from
doing absolutely nothing to you know be
like a hundred miles an hour again you
know that's like a really hard
transition I think like I can go back to
it is difficult as much I was excited to
get back so that was the first thing I
think yeah like in terms of market it
was actually for me strangely it's been
better than I expected I don't mean to
sound positive like everything's fine
it's yeah my big push and I companies be
pushy still very much on jobs and
business development but yeah that
period like just before I went on
furlough yeah that was probably like for
me like just like the lowest or like the
lowest point in terms of like ability to
succeed because I think it was just like
she's making so many calls and it's the
same thing everywhere everyone was in a
state of panic no one was hiring yeah we
are off as poor as everyone probably did
as I said and demand just fell through
the floor so I think like the positive
is that
I think things are certainly picking up
a bit certainly in my kind of area I
can't speak for recruitment in general
but I certainly feel from what I'm
hearing that things are starting to pick
up a bit which is good but I think yeah
just don't be too too hard on yourself
in those first first few days like even
again sorry yes and I specifically do
sales roles within broadly speakers the
data analytic space but I've
historically done a lot with in my
marketing technology okay
have you been approached in Business
Development corner because that's going
to be a push that everyone's going to be
told that they need to focus on you need
to get jobs need to like new with new
clients that will even exist in clients
but like how have you been approaching
it and how's it been going
yeah good good question first first like
first back like my first week was really
like yeah it's the many low-hanging
fruit which is like reach back out to
all existing clients see what's
happening on there and you know a lot
can change in a short space of time
right and six weeks is the decent period
considering what's been going on so that
was my first port of call flight BD is
what's out there
second it was like Hoover had
conversations with you know I always
keep a list of like people have had
meaningful conversations with people who
reply or at least engage with you as a
recruiter you know they're more likely
to have a conversation so that was like
my first like weeks project really was
like we engage with all customers and
also candidates as well right see what
they're doing they're like super cool
lot of them have been hard hit by
layoffs been like oh they've left of
their own accord as well so yeah I think
that was my first week where he was like
reconnect that's that the hardest bit I
think actually going from like you know
when you used to have it if you've been
up and running used to having a pipeline
you used to talking about interviews
talking about see these and a couple of
people in the cyber team carried on so
when I'm coming back and my big
achievement is like oh I spoke to a
couple of people today and interview and
it's hard mentally actually so I think
I've been prepared for life with this
piece of your business who have still
been going
try and remember that like you're coming
back to a standing mess I'll start again
yeah so that was like a really big thing
almost yea BDI initially reached out to
all those people it's really been yeah
that's the drawing board and we're
having a lot more conversations at the
moment I think this is important for
companies as well it's like taking this
time to really think innovate and create
like new strategies and you know just
kind of try different things it's not to
say to be reckless and abandon what
you're doing if it's working but I think
like we've certainly we're going to come
out of this with some new business
development strategies for sure I mean
we've typically you know God inspect our
candidates cry mourned but that works
and it's had success and it's having
more success now than it did two months
ago right for sure we've had to cook the
clients and confirm interviews however
you know in where we normally in a very
candidate short market and working and
everyone will speak to an overachieving
salesperson as you said that's change
big time and so yes so we're looking at
you know how we can sell in terms of our
services as a product you know in terms
of can't we help people or higher for
example but I saving them kind of
revenue if we were to do a 12 contract
you know there's lots of areas yeah yeah
really yeah so that's kind of a big
thing we're doing at the moment and
seeking really reach out to those people
who are also business leaders
particularly my boss is doing I'm just
going to really sign up by something
like what what's working so I think I
hate that word you know unprecedented
but it is different for sure and yeah
what's like worked in the past might not
work out so I think that's the thing is
to be able to like embrace change as
well and that's something we're
experimenting with using for example
video the voice knows trying those of
different things not just always
pitching our candidates trying a
different approach yeah just really yes
and then obviously so when you came back
yet zero jobs where you at now it's
three weeks in being the base develop
you mean trying different things where
you're like I mean large jobs we managed
to call yeah I've got five five live
jobs at one of those
is retainer let's put another yeah
obviously like so before this had you
ever sailed a retainer
where'd that come from how that how do
you approach that how did you
communicate that yeah I think there's a
couple of like factors to it firstly
like there's a company we're trying to
have more emphasis on retained work and
at least I can still that in towards of
mindset because I think it's one of the
old classics isn't it like if you don't
ask you don't get yeah I think I've know
how to retailer how many times I really
ask for I think probably not very often
I've actually got another proposal
standing at the minute could be another
one that's the thing is think is just
getting into the habit of asking making
that a cultural thing of like right okay
if we're going to negotiate our terms
which is how this one came about if
we're going to negotiate something what
can we get in return that's really what
we did was getting creative with the fee
structure that was going to be a good
offering to the claim obviously also if
we can get something up further that
works well yeah I think that was a big
thing like a company level awareness of
like this is a good thing to be doing
and people do it I think often recruits
this thing like they don't really buy
into it themselves I think they just
think I work contingent nobody asks I
think that was a big thing we did some
recruitment sorry might retain a
specific training next week as well so
again someone in to help us but yeah in
short how this one would care about was
yet to ask but also it was like it was I
mean this was a client now I've worked
with before
so yeah it's my biggest client
personally I had placed quite a few
people he helped me last year and has
already made you know some some purpose
for I'm kind of strides this year as
well so that helps I have to buy with
him I think I'm bluffing the key thing
there corner in a lot a lot of people
could've just you've done you've the way
that you've done is the way you've
always done it right and you wouldn't
have won that retainer or got that
retains work if you didn't ask I think
that's that's part of it isn't it
that's the big thing like he was
prepared to give it but I just didn't
ask him does that look like
I remember on the call yesterday I
thought I was going to the crutch moment
here's what I want I thought I was
bracing myself for the objections I kind
of prepared or I'm also going to say and
he was that yeah I don't see an issue
you know you need some commitment that's
fine and he just like came through but
think in your head sometimes I'm often
guilty of this actually I had a really
good placement come from someone who I
wasn't around in a week it was a 20
grand placement in the u.s. that was
pure look because it was like an
American guy and it was like an Italian
company and the CEO was in London I just
I can't see this kind of album anyway
yeah not happen it happens to me again
with my Swiss company in the US it came
on so I think that's a good lesson is
sometimes you can put your own mindset
and thorns into the person and you
project that yes so many questions so I
think yeah just like get rid of that and
ask the question you might be surprised
by the answer and let the fool before we
finish because I think a lot of people
can get value out of this what you said
he'd been trying different things been
trying to innovate what what have you
noticed in the last two weeks there sort
of helped you cut through was the has
had a bit of an impact on the business
development side that you've noticed I
don't know if it's sending out video
outreaches or voice and I saw them I was
there anything that so you've actually
been really surprised with that's done
really well or yeah I mean we certainly
we certainly tried video that's like
obviously a big thing we've not done it
long enough to see if it's having huge
results to be to be honest
yeah that's certainly something we're
trying LinkedIn connects it's something
that sometimes we forget about actually
just pitch in there and get going and
connected and Danny was there connecting
you can send them a personalized video
or a voice note that helps and something
I've been doing on my voice mails that
actually I've had a few callbacks from
even if they don't call me back reply to
the email which is quite nice I don't
leave them another forum
smells that week is my last light I just
say I don't hear from you I'll follow up
with you on Wednesday or Thursday or
whatever and they know I'm coming for
them then and that's actually Tim but it
seems to work to be fair they seem to be
you know not on everyone for sure those
voicemails but yeah I've had a bit more
responsive a few engagements from
callbacks actually from just let them
know if they don't call me back I'll be
going up against that so look and
cornered before we finish it fun fun
listen not right now when I'm the
recruits are on I'm Jude's comeback or
furloughed July the first you've been in
the you've been back off obviously back
on the pitch now for the last couple of
weeks what what should I be thinking
about and what would you be saying to me
yeah I think firstly something I said to
shared in my own team was my mindset was
like this is going to be hell but I was
prepared for that's because the
experience I had prior to furlough is
very different in the market now it is
picking up the bits I think first
mentally trying to stay positive
I read a really good book just before I
came back I'm convinced has helped me I
think you helped me with the retainer
it's not sales but I think the mentality
of the book helped we would the retired
and it's called the obstacles the way
such a good book I've had a few people
recommend that so but I think not
actually helped me because my client
threw up an obstacle and the the
resolution is led to a retailer and of
no less of a fee so I think that that
book helped me but it also helped me
mentally just be prepared for things and
just have a good mindset so I think
that's the key thing is be optimistic
because it's not all doom and gloom and
it's not as bad as when you were last on
furlough I think come back with high
levels of energy and activity I think
that's the key thing is still like
pretty big on quantity in a minute just
by nature of the market but I think also
like don't be too hard on yourself as
well and continue to kind of learn a
developing feed your mind with
positivity between now and your return
and particularly when you get back in
those mornings just feeding
with positivity I think it's I think
that's really helpful given the
circumstances were in yeah finally keep
your end goals in mind that's helping me
remember why you're doing it and that
this will pass this one honestly can't
absolutely love the minds that you've
called that it may honestly I think it's
awesome and last question what what's
kana most excited about in a postcode
vid world we most excited you
professionally personally well you were
you excited about personally I'm most
excited about going on the holiday I
love traveling I had a trip to Italy
books going out to Rome I don't cruise
books as well and obviously they've
they've hit the dust so I'm super
excited and personally to get back a
holiday professionally I'm actually
really excited as corny as this sounds
it's true to get back into the office
properly I'm doing like one day a week
at the midday but there's only four
movers in it's all very like
microsurgical obviously with distance to
be able to get back at the office and
just have that does and I think that's
going to like just drive everyone on and
I know that we'll all the chief so much
more together yeah kind of togetherness
in the office so professionally I'm
really looking forward to actually
getting back in the office home workings
been great but yeah there's nothing like
that birds on those sales floor in the
afternoon I know it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you really appreciate it